اهلا بكم من جديد على مسرح ابو بكر سالم
في بوليفارد رياض سيتي اعاده احدى ليالي
السعوديه الفنيه التاريخ العريق والفن
الاصيل الى قلوب عقول الجماهير العربيه
امسيه فنيه رائعه نظمتها الهيئه العامه
للترفيه لاشراف رئيس مجلس ادارتها
المستشار تركيا الشيخ وبالتعاون مع هيئه
الموسيقى و برنامج جوده الحياه وذلك
للاحتفاء بالنغم والطرب واصاله الفن
العربي عبر احياء روائع مهندس وسيد للحان
الخالد الموسيقار الراحل محمد الموجي محمد
الموجي الموسيقار المصري الذي رافق الفن
على مدار 50 عاما من حياته وترك فيه بصمات
خالده لا تنسى وسجلا فنيا لا يمكن احصائه
الموجي الذي عناق العود من الثامنه من
عمره واسست تجربه موسيقيه خالده لروائع
فنيه وسمعناها وعرفناها وحفظناها بدءا من
عام 1951 في صافيني مره مرورا باكثر من
1800 اغنيه من الالحان الاصيله وانتهاء
بالروائع الثلاث يا مالك قلبي رساله من
تحت الماء وقرات الفنجان وعلى الرغم من
رحيله في
1995 عن الحياه الا انه خلف ارثا ضخما من
الاغاني والالحان التي اشتهر بها عمالقه
الفن العربي امثال عبد الحليم حافظ وام
كلثوم وصباح وطالع المداح وغيرهم
شويه
واسالها انت وحل فيها على طول
[موسيقى]
هتقول لها انت وحل
فاكر وبس
انت وبس اللي
بيتنا
[موسيقى]
لا قدره وكلنا نترفرف علينا
اوعودي
وكلام معسول واموت واستردام
يا ولدي
يوما مكسورا
[موسيقى]
نور
اناديله
وبحبك قد عيني
حتى اكثر من
شويه الربع من مايو كانت رياضه على موعد
مع ليلى فنيه استثنائيه اصبحت ملاذا لكل
حال ومتذوق للفن العربي الاصيل واضطر
منظمها والقائمون عليها الى توسعه الحفل
عده مرات بسبب الاقبال الكبير على الحفل
كان رئيس مجلس اداره هيئه الترفيه تركيا
للشيخ اعلن عن توسعه الحفل للمره الثالثه
واعتذر عن عدم قدره توسعه اكثر من ذلك فهي
ليست ليله فنيه عاديه وانما ليلى تكريميه
للموسيقار محمد الموجي والتي تمت بحضور
كوكبه من الفنانين العرب واكثر من 130
عازفا شاركوا في احياء وتجديد الحان
الراحل
[موسيقى]
حبيبي يقولوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ازاي
اشتقت اليك فعلي
الا اشترى
كما كرمت الهيئه العامه للترفيه اسره
الراحه لمحمد الموجي تقديرا لما تركه من
بصمات فنيه خالده في تاريخ الفن العربي
نساء الطرب مساء الكلمه الحلوه مساء اللحن
الحلو واللي ما بيتنسيش استاذ محمد الموجي
الموسيقار العظيم اللي احنا استمتعنا
دلوقتي مع كل الفنانين العظماء اللي غنوا
له انا دلوقتي عايزاكم ترحبوا معايا باسره
الفنان الموسيقار العظيمه محمد الموهي الف
مبروك الف مبروك
[موسيقى]
تفضلوا
شكرا
ابوكو قوي باي باي
وقع من الفتاه الجميله والتي تعبر عن تاثر
الجماهير في الحفل وعن الاثر الكبير الذي
تركته والحان الموسيقار الراحل في نفوسهم
هي مسابقه اعلن عنها رئيس مجلس اداره هيئه
الترفيه تركيا للشيخ تتضمن تصوير كل محب
للطرب الاصيل والالحان محمد الموجي
لفيديوهات قصيره لا تتجاوز الدقيقه يظهر
فيها تاثرهم وتفاعلهم مع الحفل
[موسيقى]
المجنون
يساعدني حتى
يا ولدي
ايه
[موسيقى]
قالت يا ولدي تحزن
فالحب عليك هو المكت
وب ولم يخلو حفل تكريم الراحل من اللحظات
المؤثره التي تصدرتها مشاهد تاثر ابن
الموسيقار الراحل يحيى الموجي خلال عزف
مقطوعه ضمن احد اشهر الحان والديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونحن في تفاعلكم تواصلنا مع ابن الموسيقى
محمد الموجي الذي خص البرنامج بهذه
الكلمات نتابع
في البدايه احب اشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشكر خادم الحرمين الشريفين
سلمان بن عبد العزيز واحب اشكركم ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان على
الاستقبال الرائع لاسره الموجي
والحفاوه البالغه ومش قادر اعبر عن فرحتي
بتكريم محمد الموجي
بالحدث المذهل ده اللي لم يحدث من قبل
واحب اشكر طبعا معالي المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ على استقباله لنا
واستقبلنا في بيته ومرحب بينا
ولصقته في كمان في انه اداني كمان بتاعته
علشان اعزف بها في الحفله
قعدت بها الصوره بتاعت الماء العب بيها
الصوره بتاع القناه بتاع السنه بتاعه
الماء وكمان قديمه من اغلى الكمنجات اللي
في العالم
قديمه جدا
يعني عمرها حوالي 300 سنه فالحقيقه كنت
خايف عليها جدا
وبلعب عليها وانا حريص جدا
طبعا في البدايه
احنا من شهرين بنجهز للاغاني اتصل بيا يا
معلم المستشار تركي وقال لي
احنا عايزين نعمل احتفال عليك بالمستقرار
محمد الموجي وعايزين نعمل اغانيه بشكل
جديد
تكتب لها وتحط لها توزيع او استرالي تتعمل
بشكل حديث شويه عشان برضو الشباب
اللي طالعين اللبان دول
يقدروا يستوعبوا ويسمعوا الحان الموسيقات
محمد الموجي شكلها الجديد
وبالهارمونيات وبالاركسترا
فطبعا يعني بدلنا موجود جامد جدا
وعملنا حوالي 5 برو طبعا مايسترو
والمايسترو فايد ومع المطربين طبعا قمت
بالاشراف على العمل نفسه
وكنت بسمع المطرب كل واحد لوحده
ومحفظهم وبقول لهم على الكلمات لان انا
طبعا حافظ موسيقى محمد الموجي كلها
بالكلمات كمان يعني حفظتهم كلهم تقريبا
الاغاني
[موسيقى]
وقمت باسراف على العزف على عزف الفرقه
الموسيقيه طبعا كانوا رائعين
وكمان يعني انا مش عارف اعبر عن فرحتي
فعلا
محمد الموجي وبشكر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وشكرا جزيلا